it is something no one wants to think  about but it's important for our local  emergency agencies to prepare for the  worst today clark county fire metro and  community ambulance ran mass casualty  drills over at southern hills hospital  dispatchers practiced taking calls  working with nurses and ambulance crews  to make a plan to deal with an influx of  patients and beginning treatment  immediately  we want to make it as real as possible  you know that way it truly stresses our  system stresses the county system and we  can really think through every aspect  that may come up in one of these  instances  some of those who participated in the  drill were working back on one october  and say while it's hard thinking about  something like that happening again they  know this preparation will ultimately  save lives